salut eric a suivi ce qui se passe en
thaïlande les gamins coincé dans une
grotte
au gouvernement thaï a reçus une liste
de plongeurs secouristes c'est quand à
touristes elle a l'air facile mais quand
elle est inondée y aller impraticable
il faut une grande force mentale pour
faire de la plongée souterraine faut
être un peu barjot c'est très très
dangereux étant donné le niveau de l'eau
est levée la visibilité très réduite à
peine la largeur des épaules entre des
courants très forts à cet endroit
disparu il ya neuf jours les 12 garçons
et leur entraîneur ont été piégés dans
les galeries inondées de la grotte
bonjour
bonjour ils sont là vous êtes combien 13
13 et surtout suivant on peut sortir de
la prote maintenant
une gamme d'armoires et guettant en
rodage y'a quoi car il va falloir leur
faire faire une plongée de cinq heures
si on essaie de faire faire à ces gamins
tout la plongée tout ce qu'on récupérera
la sortie cet écart
oxygène se faisant rares du pays entier
attend avec angoisse la suite des
événements
durant ce à quoi une idée assez
délirante mais il y a une technique que
tu es le seul à maîtriser
c'est de la folie c'est contraire à
l'éthique c'est illégal il ya déjà un
maquis ya laissé la vie
si on fait rien ce qu'on sortira de là
c'est les canards selon vous il faut
s'attendre à des pertes
ouais
ça va rsa va donner moins une minute
ok on va y arriver
[Musique]